45 seconds of two freakin logos as usual
darkness instantly tells me there's
going to be some narration in this bitch
you ever look at someone and wonder
narration this baby memory should have
fallen off the track and smashed on the
floor thereby giving us a good reason
for why we can't remember baby stuff or
or how about a memory troll with 18
million hit points and infinite mana
discount marble man Dez that's fear he's
really good at keeping Riley safe at
that age Riley would have ran right over
that power cord and wouldn't have given
to its about it also movie steals its
entire premise from Herman's head how
did this child's brand new emotions know
they hate broccoli let alone what it
even is this is disgust that's anger
okay so far we have joy sadness fear
disgust and anger and that's it the rest
of the movie no love no loyalty no
competitive spirit no logic no Riley if
you don't eat your dinner you're not
going to get any dessert how is anger
already reading a newspaper about no
dessert before Riley's dad said anything
about it great newspaper by the way but
we're still sending this because we're
assholes right after you eat none of the
other emotions have any control over
anger even though they are all within
stopping anger from pulling these levers
distance these are Riley's memories
which are somehow not shot from her POV
but I guess we get the point
goofball Island is my personal favor
Riley's memory storage system is a
discount Pinterest well I'm definitely
on some kind of watch list now thanks
Pixar I love honesty Island Louie
creates a series of islands that all
seem worthy of their own emotion
character thing but whatever the islands
of personality are what make Riley Riley
and we five main emotions with direct
access to an action control board have
no say in the matter whatsoever
let's get those memories down a
long-term dam is a lot of long-term
memory she's supposedly gonna hold on to
forever apparently this is the first
time Riley is noticing the house going
up for sale or given any warning they're
going to move also Pixar dips into the
Toy Story well for a cheap family is
moving plot starter neither eats nor
mutants are attacking the Golden Gate
Bridge in the scene
Riley clearly has no understanding of
the real estate market in San Francisco
or she'd be freaking out over how much
money her parents are gonna earn when
they flip this thing see this is the
problem with choosing for negative
emotions and only one positive one is
the five main Riley emotions she's
constantly gonna be fighting for any
scrap of happiness
err and a desk over there hockey let
goes there put your chair there well the
traffic over there there
I would anger sadness fear and disgust
have some sort of weird say and how this
room looks movie van won't be here until
Thursday why does the movie band status
cause more than 10 memories to occur he
makes a move she's closing in Hey hockey
once again saves America what the heck
is Rockley on pizza movie continues its
assault on broccoli congratulations San
Francisco you've ruined beets up
oh no Chicago did that what kind of a
pizza place only serves one kind of
pizza the non-existent movie kind the
one you find in screenplays that drive
the emotions of the plot movie does some
kind of explaining but things are going
weird with the memories and core
memories and the emotions but does such
a poor job of it that I'm left thinking
just about anything might happen which
is exactly the case we only got capital
to last a month man to parent openly
discusses family financial trouble in
full auditory view of concerned child
cliche somebody order a broccoli pizza
hey love this dream but apparently
dreams are mind-numbing lis literal
directly referenced things that happen
during the day eat me I'm organic is my
new pick-up line
considering you five emotions literally
control Riley's actions during a week
time it's crazy you have no control over
dream time make sure that all the
sadness stays in the circle sadness
imprisonment since we moved well crying
on your first day of school while
introducing yourself to your classmates
it's basically the worst day of school
ever
way to go slack ass emotions you're not
in headquarters without you Riley can't
be happy apparently she can't be sad
either because you're also not there but
that's something we'll gloss over also
this is why you don't make four of your
five core emotions negative ones will be
puts a whole bunch of bull between joy
and Riley's brain just for the sake of
the runtime of the film
Riley's headquarters looks an awful lot
like the CN tower I'd be great to be
back out on the ice here's an
interesting quandary the movie is into
this point
supposedly joy and sadness are in a
place where they're physically stuck
until they can figure out how to get
back to headquarters
but what apper parents suddenly moved
back to Minnesota she reunited with all
her friends and everything but back to
normal what a magic back eyo Manor
Riley's head and suck them back into
headquarters this in itself is sad as
mom's head appears to be captained by
sadness more than any of the other
emotions but also and more importantly
why are all of mom's emotions females
and Riley's emotions live in a co-ed
door the father is thinking about a full
game of hockey while eating that's
racist but also in
practical unfortunately for joined
sadness they just happened to be walking
across the goofball Island bridge at the
very moment it decided it was going to
collapse training from the Prometheus
school of running away from things
actually helps these emotional gals are
we getting close yeah just another ride
why sadness pretending to know which way
to go phone numbers we don't need all
these they're in her phone but this
movie is genuinely clever and we love it
so take our sins as a function of us
just being dumb guerrillas but Riley is
a millennial and it's doubtful she ever
memorized phone numbers this is more of
a joke for people in their 30s who grew
up memorizing numbers but when the
cellphone age began suddenly didn't have
to you know Riley definitely ain't happy
here but isn't she kind of happy singing
the song she's dentally not disgusted
scared or angry so how do these emotions
stay happy
merrily Riley's long-lost imaginary
friend goes around stealing long-term
memories I mean one is he the guy
responsible for losing socks in the
dryer two also guy who can certainly
help out is kind of embarrassed about
his Riley memory stealing and thereby
takes off running instead of helping
because horton hears a who enjoy the joy
how does news about the various emotions
travel outside of headquarters to
imaginary friends or employees of a
human head is that the weirdest thing
I've ever written yes it is just want to
be clear the imaginary friend inside of
Riley's head just sprained his leg wha
why not walking we're takin that train
of thought movie just keeps inventing
ways out of the bull scenarios it puts
its characters into strategy there are
four stages this is the first Riley's
own joy and sadness are now in her
abstract thought and I just lost the
battle with my own existentialism
I was Riley talked into playing hockey
again especially since she's completely
shut down since joy left headquarters
apparently one's ability to play hockey
is dependent upon the ability to keep
memory balls in a thing perhaps this is
an exploration of Riley's heart but the
heart never really makes an appearance
in this movie physically speaking here
you go Diggle monster tickle monster
Riley's dreams are truly the weirdest
thing ever because they're all based on
earlier events does she ever have that
dream where she's trying to get
somewhere but no matter how far she
travels she never gets any closer what
how did the cops and bing-bong get that
freaking far that quickly it's where
they keep Riley's darkest
years ah apparently there is no room for
happy thoughts in the subconscious and
couldn't some of the darkest fears
popped up in Imaginationland I guess
that would have ruin the production
design that's broccoli goddamn
I know it's common for kids to dislike
vegetables but this assault on broccoli
is offensive that is delicious and
nutritious what is this a cat
subconscious how is a vacuum cleaner a
subconscious thing something we're
barely aware of but not quite sure is
real I guess this is why the hairs on
our neck stand up every time we walk
into a Sears instead of lifting up the
bloom cage joint tries to do this I mean
we see her do this with a different
balloon down here so it's not like
balloons are super heavy in this place
honesty eyeline crashes into the train
of thought and so the train gets
derailed but doesn't she still have a
train of thought about running away if
we're making physical representations of
abstract things does this mean she's not
thinking anymore am i overthinking this
I'm pretty sure I am but it's amazing
how convenient all these physical
interruptions are to the clock well what
would have happen if it had missed and
just fall it could emotions die see look
how convenient it all is you say who
cares it's a kids movie about the inside
of a brain but I say I care damn it
because cheap tension does not equate as
real tension joy is a dick in brain land
this is basically manslaughter I mean
see there's an unseen villain at work in
this movie something that knows joy is
trying to get back to headquarters but
is doing everything in its power to keep
her from doing so is it the nothing I
think it's the nothing and now that joy
is falling down here with Bing bong it
means it's a harmless fall because this
movie is not going to kill joy which
then undercuts the earlier cheap tension
train bolt feeding further how could
this kid have forgotten this first day
of school sadness in the few days since
it happened that's literally not
possible listen her stories all day I
guess this is a tear-jerking scene but
doesn't really make sense if you
consider how off and the movie showed us
these five emotion controlling Riley's
actions so the stories were probably
made up by you assholes too you flip-top
all over this movie from acting parental
and protective of Riley to actually
being Riley I just want Ryan to be happy
and sadness wants her to be sad and
anger once her to be how could this have
ended any other way the deck was stacked
against happiness from the start
imaginary Rock and wagon ex machina why
is there a ramp in the middle of all
these Forgotten memories and it looks
like it's a giant book did that get down
here imaginary hero sacrifices himself
to save the mind cliche why does he need
to disappear all of a sudden also why
did he disappear so quickly his hand
evaporated as soon as they got down here
and now he's completely gone but Joey's
okey-dokey what's up with that they fell
into the forgotten at the same time
right Oh
bing-bong oh sorry I was getting sad
about his death there for real but then
she said his name again
Joey gets the idea to follow the trail
of sadness balls to find sadness but why
can't this be from earlier when she was
being dragged all over the place and
touching the bottom row I reject this
notion that sadness can just make every
single one of these memories sad by just
touching them and if you tell me certain
memories are gonna be looked back upon
with sadness just because of all that
she's going through and I'm gonna tell
you all these other memories on the
higher shelf should be affected too you
can't just pick and choose that yo funny
how all the other islands immediately
crashed but this one is staying up
because family I guess if it's that
strong does its survival really depend
on whether or not Riley gets on that bus
I am positive this is crazy indeed but
that rainbow wagon rocket worked so just
get on with it already well we've been
dicks to this movie and this is the type
of quality Pixar was hammering out
almost every year until Disney decided
to make them turn out sequels to
everything this is a return to form and
will not to sins off like tragic vampire
romance island yes Twilight
Island Oh everyone shut up we banned
Island poop that's just phase say what
amazing that could sum up an 11-year old
girl with five ping Islands but a year
later there's a whole Caribbean out
there because the age of 12 is Magic
sorry what now you're controlling her
every move again you weren't doing that
while she walked for her parents to the
ice or interacted with that boy but way
to make hockey a video game basically
movie but we still love our girl you are
that girl this entire end credits
sequence is inspired and awesome
and evil Island
what do they got there apes but they're
not so big
I'd flip through catalogs and wonder
what kind of dining set defines me as a
person
anybody give you dog it's triple na
quadruple system her life
I wonder what that means is funny this
smell just like tortoise me it's good
it's like it's like has been erased
erased from existence